did you guys see uh what's going on with
candace owens yeah indy 100 australians
react to candace owens's call to for us
to invade
over cover restrictions uh and we also
have this uh from time
u.s conservatives want to save australia
from tyranny australians aren't
interested so the media is running this
claim because candace owens made a joke
where she was like paraphrasing she's
like look how bad it is in australia i
mean when are we deploying obviously i
say that in jest but you know you look
at and so they're like oh publish it
kenneth owens wants to invade australia
this is what this is what happens when
when you have people who believe this
we're screwed man well and the other
thing about it is there's tons of
complaints in australia but they know
that if they say anything there's some
very prominent personalities other
people we've talked to who've made it
clear they can't talk about australia
publicly even when they're not
physically there because of what might
happen to their friends or their family
back home
it is at that level and i have friends
and other people that i know in
australia and i asked them the question
but i don't trust the answers because i
do genuinely feel that they are afraid
to even speak it on social media and dms
because they know police show up look at
people's homes or facebook posts in
australia
freaking hell no no i'll shout out avi
amini who is rebel news uh journalist in
australia doing
god's work is an understatement uh it's
it's over the top there they show up to
your house and they they arrest you for
organizing a protest
it was was considered to be like the idw
publication when the intellectual dark
web was all big and everything and they
are completely defensive of they are pro
mandate pro lockdown pro camp
and then uh it was mike cernovich he
tweeted out one of these stories like a
video of a guy being indefinitely
quarantined and he was like where's
quillette you'd think a freedom you know
publication would have a lot to write
about
and then someone said something my
response was avi yemeni is you know on
the ground he's covering these stories
so there you go let's call let's call a
spade a spade here what's happening in
australia is tyranny it's over the top
it's draconian it's it's government
literally forcing its will in the most
nastiest disgusting ways on the people
when the people don't want it there have
been major protests there have been
major crackdown against protests and i
think one of the reasons why politicians
in the united states and journalists in
the united states aren't really talking
about it is because they really want to
implement some of the same policies here
in the united states and you could see
that they call for the same things the
same mandates the same restrictions the
same lockdowns and it's utterly insane
now melbourne just a few days ago
announced that they're getting rid of
their lockdowns they had 262 days of
stay-at-home orders of people being
locked down not being able to go outside
people were screaming outside of their
balconies just a few hours ago because
they lifted some of these restrictions
and they allowed people to go out at
night so again what's happening in
australia is just beyond
draconian beyond 1984 china is literally
blushing at what australia is willing to
do against their own people and for that
other article to say the australian
people don't want this how do you know
are you are you talking to all the
australian people because there sure as
hell has been a lot of protests a lot of
people standing up a lot of people
speaking out even though they face the
full might of a technocratic police
state that shows up at their door
because they spread wrong think on the
internet luke the australians don't want
this they don't want liberation and i
know because time magazine says
australian lawmakers took to twitter to
school american critics of the country's
kova 19 public health measures that
proves it yeah cause people because it's
it's it these lawmakers were elected by
the people that that means they're
they're the will of the people and the
australian people are very happy that
all this is happening what's
extraordinary in the united states and
in most of the western world is how
often they have not utilized the
legislative process how often this has
circumvented the legislative process
circumvented the judicial process who
mostly sort of cowered rather than deal
with it you just had executive orders by
unelected officials who just
basically put us in a real live milgram
experiment let's see how much we can get
away with let's see how much people will
tolerate unfortunately we found out a
lot of people would tolerate much more
than we would like so i i tweeted out
there was a picture of the quarantine
camps i think was in melbourne and
someone said quarantine camp i put
asterisk concentration camp and then it
was some writer from colette or whatever
and then no no it was it was it was
clear lemon herself she was like we are
not building death camps blah blah blah
and i was like well i didn't say death
camp i did say concentration camp trying
to allude to what these things could be
but then she ends up writing in the
spectator that you know popular american
pundit tim poole says this that and
otherwise and i'm like yo if you really
want to call me out man
like please do so because i would love
to point out how much of a coward claire
lehmann of quillette is and how their
publication are a bunch of cowards and i
will tell you this
i'll say two things if google ever came
to me and said show us your vaccine
documentation or we're deleting your
channel i'd be like
i do nothing i don't
don't believe many ideas tim the
but the issue is this it's um i'm going
to lose my thought again robert it was
the election
i was going to say one more thing
because those are two things the other
thing is if the united states was was in
the position that australia was in with
camps and permanent lockdown i would be
saying the exact same things i am now i
don't care what the risks are they can
come they can come to my house and they
say you're going on definite quarantine
and
i'm not going to shut up and you gave me
time to think what i was going to say
the media pretends not to understand a
joke when they want to demonize the
person who said it it was clearly a joke
and they pretended it was a serious
statement and not to bring it back to
the ppc maxine bernier the leader of the
ppc at one point put out a tweet that
said maoists have invaded our government
and are trying to take over making a
joke about how it looks like you know
we're in imitating china mao's china and
canada the journal
or one of the one of the media ran with
it as though he was seriously saying
we're being infiltrated by communists
and
the media when it wants to land base
someone pretends that a joke is not a
joke
i think they genuinely don't know what
jokes are i i mean that literally i'm
not being sarcastic or facetious i
actually don't think they understand
jokes yeah that's mark robert's argument
he argues that stated societies can't
handle comedy it's it's so i tweet
things that are often nonsensical and
they're all taken literally by the left
and i'm just like i so i have a friend
who is i don't know if i'm assuming
we're still friends a very prominent
hollywood personality who told me
messaged me saying you need to
understand that when you tweet these
things there are people who think
they're real and i was like
please
please if that is true and i think it
might be
we are in serious trouble because like
when i post something i posted
president biden as cornholio because he
did the portfolio thing i said who did
this it's so disrespectful to the
president
they're oh you know my favorite was when
i said impeach the queen
so it was like i don't remember exactly
what happened but something happened
with queen elizabeth and i said impeach
queen elizabeth and a website newsguide
certified ran it as fact
personality timpool calls for impeaching
the queen and then i became adamant that
wikipedia included the statement because
it was a reliable source it was
fact-based
in fairness someone who doesn't know you
and doesn't know your political leanings
or your position might think you're like
you're a very sensitive individual who
found it to be especially no not even
though the who did this to joe biden
it's it's disrespectful but um
things get taken literally
on twitter twitter is awesome and then
things if you put in a hashtag sarcasm
everyone's like oh you think your
followers are so stupid they don't know
you're joking yeah so there's it's a
lose-lose have you seen michael mouse's
tweets today
baldwin
it can only be good i can't say some of
his tweets
i was laughing like crazy
wow
i just tweeted a bunch of i tweet a lot
of just like silly stuff i retweeted she
won head she said i effing hate liberals
i don't have any other politics and that
was just fantastic and she did it
because this like liberal guy was
insulting her because she was making fun
of alex baldwin or something
uh i don't know whatever twitter is fun
twitter's not now i gotta go see i'm
glad i put my phone on the floor so i
don't get to go go see michael malus's
tweets but that's next on my wonderful
there's so many memes out there did you
see his tweets
oh my gosh so hot
let me see if i can pull something up
michael you you
have to troll yeah you you rub scallion
i don't think i can no don't read this
on me oh my god
he's just been going off all day it's
been great i've been in i've got to be
able to read at least one so you you you
understand like what he's saying but i
don't know if i can i'm trying to find
one
all right um
oh boy okay
i am calling for a total and complete
shutdown of hollywood film production
until our country's representatives can
figure out what is going on here alec
baldwin
that's the one but below it is i'm just
going to read it script he says in the
culture wars it's currently a draw
between charlottesville and alec baldwin
oh that's brutal that was
brutal
oh my god anyway
back to the main point
the the when you are a rigid ideologue
you don't understand jokes right npc is
probably like the best descriptor for a
lot of these people so like i was saying
like i have a friend who's like you know
people don't realize you're not being
serious with these things and i was like
isn't that really crazy so then i
started tweeting after she told me this
i started uh posting things on twitter
after i'd say a joke i'd say the above
tweet is not serious i'm told i have to
put this here because people aren't
smart enough to understand
unfortunately that may be reality the
other issue is like
i at some point in time you appreciate
how historically general populations
didn't know of the atrocities that were
going on in their own in their own
countries because of the fact that the
media was being censored and strictly
limited by the government and i i can
wholeheartedly believe that there are
some australians who don't even think
it's that bad in australia right now
because they just don't know and they
don't even know what's going on in their
own country because the media can't
report on it freely even though they
have to walk around with qr codes in
some places to get permission to get
into and now they're implementing one of
the strictest vax passports than
anywhere else in the world where if you
don't comply you can't work in the
public sector in the private sector you
go into a business that you're not
supposed to be in or a business that's
indoor thousands of dollars of fines
levied against you and the business for
just existing as a human being and again
what's happening there there's there's
police officers when people are
gathering for a protest they just open
fire with less lethal munitions and
rubber bullets right away
they don't even ask any questions
arresting people for walking in nature
by themselves because they weren't
wearing a mask thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time